salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est sous un pont
dans une petite ville ouais un pont qui
a l'air bien sympa et bien passant
élément de Quentin est déjà sur quelque
chose donc ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on le remonte tout de suite et qu'on
vous casse pas la tête avec une intro
d'une heure allez c'est parti
on va mettre le gant quand même pour
éviter de se blesser toujours mettre des
gants surtout que c'est des clous et
c'est de la rouille donc c'était sous le
pont c'est étonnant parce que cet
endroit est fait normalement peut-être
que c'est un objet récent oh
d'accord ok bah déjà il y a des traces
ça a été fait mais pas chaîne de vélo
et bien sûr on est en compagnie de rasta
qui est pas trop informé il a une copine
qui vient de partir prendre le train
alors il est un peu triste
il va nous faire comme Hatchi là il va
retourner à la gare tous les jours mais
la température ça fait plaisir là on est
en plein été et pourtant il fait bon tu
dirais combien en température ressentie
et température d'eau
je sais pas encore d'eau mais je vais
finir
directement en maillot avec ce
magnifique temps on est encore dans le
sud pour ceux qui se demandent c'est
juste c'est que ça peut arriver de temps
en temps
ok
c'est
le début de la richesse
OK
donc déjà on a une pile
donc ça bien pour la dépollution
une de vélo
il y en a des choses
ok une clé plate
dans son plastique d'origine OK
mais ça c'est peut-être une météo encore
très aimanté très dense on verra à
étudier
allez on continue
encore alors c'est très très très nul là
pour l'instant il y a Baptiste qui tire
les abonnés pendant que je pêche enfin
c'est pas une abonnée bon ça va
alors il a le droit on va dire allez
premier lancer pour ma part j'ai rejoint
la partie un petit peu après Quentin
et là j'espère faire des découvertes qui
vont vraiment le démoraliser et lui dire
et lui dire voilà Quentin c'est qui le
patron aujourd'hui de la pêche à
l'aimant allez vraiment ce qu'on a oh un
petit rasoir celui-là je m'en sers pas
on a aussi une petite pièce de 2
centimes et une pièce de 1 centime et
ben écoutez on continue avec les petites
pièces c'est toujours drôle à trouver
j'ai quelque chose
ah non c'est un phare ou un réveil
regarde c'est un réveil je crois un
réveil ancien
tu sais tu appuies au dessus là
c'est le lundi matin quand tu pètes un
plomb
il y a encore un gros truc ici là
ouais ça se lève ça se lève ça se lève
quelques kilos
un panneau
alors c'est quoi celui-là
ok
on va le mettre en place
comme ça on nous laisse tranquille
voilà travaux en cours je crois que j'ai
eu quelque chose qui était bien au
milieu
tu es prêt mon petit Quentin
ouais
il m'attendait
[Musique]
c'est plus un morceau de pot
d'échappement d'une moto le diamant
un gros morceau qui vient
ouais ouais il était pas loin du pot
d'échappement donc peut-être que c'est
un bout de la mobylette
c'est un caddie et un sac avec un sac
c'est le haut d'un caddie
[Applaudissements]
on commence par regarder
le sac est vide
pour l'instant c'est pas encore un
copain mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a écrit une petite
cuillère parfaite en bon état en plus
regardez le ce coquin
il est en train de la monter
ça tombe ça tombe pas en fait moins bien
c'est pas beau ça
c'est ce qu'on a ici
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette montre
qu'est-ce que c'est ça
Baptiste qu'est-ce que c'est ça
c'est une munition une balle de car 98
je crois
un peu de militaria
parce que c'est
vrai
que 15 fois
il y a plein de bois mais
oh là là
une fois qu'on a enlevé ça
il y a une sacoche
malheureusement
je prends la casquette
je retourne la casquette et j'ai quelque
chose de bien au bout de l'aimant
il était là-bas tout à droite
et il a un poids correct
c'est pas une météorite ça
c'est la fonte
alors ça c'est super dense des fois ça
peut être des résidus d'explosion
pendant la guerre d'obus ou de bombe ou
même des vraiment du métal qui a subi
des fortes contraintes parce que là
c'est vraiment étonnant c'est super
dense bon tu le peser regarde
c'est bon pour le ferrailleur je pense
pas que
pour le caddie
couleur blanche
c'est rigolo elle est en plastique assez
d'entraînement
c'est pour fin mars non je pense
c'est sympa
manipulation c'est ça c'est même pas
tirer c'est manipulé ouais si vous êtes
abonné que vous reconnaissez votre chien
on s'excuse et vous pouvez garder les
bébés
c'est les bébés de youtubeur il va très
cher
oh
ade
[Musique]
une nouvelle copine
oh ça brille
oh oui une lame de couteau
et pas n'importe quel couteau il est
magnifique
waouh c'est couleur
sympa
parce qu'il est bien aiguisé
pas mal pas mal bah ça c'est restaurant
c'est plus qu'à trouver un manche
on va voir ce qu'on arrive à choper sous
ce pont
[Musique]
va venir il va te péter la gueule alors
là j'ai trouvé ça avec un M
c'est assez dense je saurais pas dire ce
que c'est si vous avez une idée en
commentaire ouais le plus près possible
du bord
oh oui alors ça c'est une enceinte une
enceinte JBL
peut-être
un certain niveau peut-être mais ah oui
en plus tu as le truc
en tout cas si vous voulez pêcher des
enceintes JBL comme nous n'hésitez pas à
aller voir le site de maison de la
détection avec le code promo pêcheur de
trésor qui offre 5% sur toute la
boutique c'est ça nous on utilise les
membres barbarianes c'est le meilleur
vraiment du marché il a une force de
1600 kg il pèse environ un kilo 5 à 2 kg
mais pour commencer on conseille le
terror ça fait déjà bien la faire il
faut assurer parce que là le match
tinder il va me demander ce qu'on a
péché
tu vas te calmer oui alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a on a une télécommande de portail
allant de voiture ou de portail un an de
voiture une Nissan Quentin tiens une
petite Nissan
un vrai pour l'instant la meurt 3 et
c'est le chien noir ça se venchère ça on
s'est décalé un petit peu plus loin du
pont pour un endroit qui ne sera pas
fait sûrement on va regarder ce qu'on a
bah ouais voilà déjà c'est des plus gros
objets et c'est des objets anciens donc
donc c'est intéressant
alors
qu'est-ce que c'est ça Quentin c'est
quelque chose
oh oui un cœur
ah c'est beau
bien joué
ça va
le travail ben moi il y a marqué un truc
sur mon cœur quand même attends on va
essayer de le nettoyer
Louis
c'est un portefeuille
American Tourister
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est un bijou
et la pièce
elle est là
donc des sous allemande une adresse aux
États-Unis quelqu'un qui s'est fait un
voyage en Europe faudrait qu'on regarde
si on le trouve sur
Facebook ou quoi ça normalement Gruber
on va regarder l'adresse sur Google Maps
pour vous mais l'endroit où habitez
cette personne ça peut être très drôle
très loin d'ici en tout cas
ma belle trouvaille c'est cool avec la
petite pièce souvenirs là il est
tellement resté dans l'eau avec la carte
que ça imprimé la carte sur le ah oui
oui sur le papier
sur la GoPro
bon si vous savez ce que c'est en
commentaire
nul allez on continue toujours à cet
endroit qui réserve quand même des
surprises visiblement ah mince je me
suis accroché au bord
c'est un morceau de roue de vélo donc il
y a pas qu'un seul vélo
et j'ai aperçu quelque chose tout à
l'heure là par là est-ce qu'il va venir
ah ouais ouais
en plus tu sais quoi on peut le garder
celui-là
impeccable ça voilà comment trouver un
balai gratuitement dans le canal c'était
le tutoriel de pêcheur de trésor et on
se dit à très vite pour un nouveau
tutoriel de pêcheur de trésor avec cette
fois-ci la recherche d'un aspirateur
troisième endroit à visiter juste à côté
du pont on a commencé on est passé de
l'autre côté cette fois-ci je viens à
peine de jeter mon aimant là-bas au fond
et j'ai déjà quelque chose qui vient oh
suspense ça se soulève
Quentin j'ai besoin de ton aimant on
dirait qu'il y a du bois ça peut être un
truc cool c'est assez lourd donc essaie
de jeter plus devant je crois que c'est
une sorte de piquet
attends
c'est bizarre la forme c'est un poteau
je m'attendais à mieux il y a une laisse
de chien accrochés
donc c'est pas de l'alu c'est un alliage
un peu spécial
tu as vu vraiment c'est rare de le
choper par là le panneau d'habitude
c'est plus le coincé là dessus à la
limite mais
il était pas dans la base
ok ah oui ah oui quand même pas juste ok
les munitions de calibre 12
c'est peut-être du 16 ça
numéro 6
70 max 1050 bars elles sont pas
françaises
intéressants intéressants donc c'est pas
du tout c'est plus petit on va les
mettre là et on va retirer
parce que du coup c'est intéressant
ce qui est bizarre c'est que je sais
plus trop où j'avais tiré
on va voir
plaisir je dirais pas non
un outil alors ça c'est un marteau
d'ardoisier il me semble et il est
totalement en fer donc c'est sympa c'est
c'est surtout bien ancien
ça c'est de la découverte que j'aime
bien
100% faire
donc ouais difficile à dater mais très
ancien
j'ai un objet
pas très gros mais
tout de suite ce que c'est j'ai pas
réussi à retrouver une munition
c'est bizarre quand même mais bon elle
est pleine sauce
OK
il s'est mis plein de boules et moi
aussi ça fait mal aux jambes c'est
chiant en plus pour les enlever ça
arrache les poils
donc pas cool ça a pas cool rasta reste
sur le chemin c'est bien allez allez
allez
le trousseau de clés ça c'est pas jeune
ça c'est vraiment tout ce qui était
perdu un petit moment sympa alors ça y
est ça y est il a été retrouvé donc il
est faut savoir qu'il est recherché
depuis ce matin et du coup c'est même
pas grâce à nous parce qu'il est plein
de
il est pas de collier ni rien mais le
monsieur l'a reconnu
il est plein de boules
qui ressemble à ton chien sur le bord du
canal c'est pas à toi
avec plaisir
alors là j'ai attrapé quelque chose dans
la canal qui vit doucement pour pas
qu'il s'échappe là tu nous fais un petit
remake de Man vs Wild alors c'est en
plein milieu
j'espère que ouais c'est intéressant
alors là pour savoir on s'est un petit
peu décalé d'endroit on est toujours
dans la même ville
elle est même pas aimantée non
une chaise
en plastique
[Musique]
qui est
assis 5 centimes en vrai des pièces ici
c'est pas des vœux il y a peut-être une
casse quelque part parce que j'en ai
fait une aussi là tout à l'heure là j'ai
mis la leçon
donc ça peut être bon signe je pense
qu'il y aura une caisse on garde de
l'espoir en plus quand tu as mangé un
cassoulet donc dans tous les cas il y
aura des caisses aujourd'hui mais moi je
préférais qu'elle soit dans le canal
alors j'ai un cassoulet avant d'aller
pêcher c'est vraiment un assassinat
ça devrait être interdit ah ouais on est
en extérieur heureusement le retour en
camion là encore une pièce 5 centimes
encore ouais ouais je pense que tu es
pas loin de la caisse
salut
j'ai eu quelque chose mais juste au bord
allez montre que tu fais de la bonne
gonflée
de merde
bravo quand même
sans calibre 12 plein
ça devient intéressant
et une fourchette aussi en bon état
comme ça dans le seau du travail qu'on
garde
une montre
elle a pris l'eau
elle est morte
voyez même pas la marque elle a pris
l'eau mais bon
ça reste sympa
OK
ça faisait longtemps
c'est grave stylé sympa elles ont pris
l'eau quand même je vais les ouvrir dans
tous les cas on va le vélo
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que ce sac là déjà il
devait être en jeu je pense normalement
première barrière et ensuite même une
fois une fois ouverte
mais il faut ouvrir je pense que oui
allez on continue on s'est décaler un
petit peu on va voir ce qu'on arrive à
trouver ici
sous le pont c'était effectivement déjà
bien fait par d'autres pêcheurs
allemands donc autant se décaler et on
voit tout de suite que décrocher carte
dépend on va quand même pas mal de
choses alors là j'ai fait un petit
antivol de vélo et une oui il est
même pas cassé il est juste tombé d'un
bateau
et le petit rasta est toujours là
ça va
qu'est-ce qui se passe
oh la proto
bah bizarrement on en est pas trouvé
aujourd'hui
dépasse à linge aussi j'en fais de
toutes les couleurs et alors de pêche
qui est bien mangé mais qui avait de
beaux yeux
là regardez là ce que j'ai j'espère ne
pas le perdre et oui le petit téléphone
de dealer
classique
ça fait toujours plaisir ça parce qu'on
sait qu'avec les barbariens on peut
avoir ce genre de choses que les petits
aimants ils ratent c'est cool et une
pile en plus pour la dépollution et une
bouteille de protoxyde d'azote
c'est cool c'est cool c'est cool c'est
cool c'est cool
hop le petit antivol qui est encore une
fois est fermé
on a un bout quand même
oh j'avais vu ça
cartouche de CO2 un mec quelquefois
dites nous en commentaire à quoi ça sert
ce type de cartouche de CO2 elle a pas
l'air vide
quelque chose
allez un des envoises-le
comme ça c'est qu'il va venir
[Musique]
bonjour Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner vous pouvez nous donner un petit
coup de main
je pense qu'il nous manque pas
grand-chose pour le faire bouger 1 2 3
c'est un beau poisson
[Applaudissements]
on va aller chercher on va aller
chercher le travail
tu as l'impression que ça va venir mais
c'est lourd
on va prendre le travail on va le mettre
à l'arbre
c'est la question c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas partir bon
ben voilà on a pas réussi même avec de
l'aide donc on a ramené le tire fort 2
tonnes on va attacher cet arbre oui
attendre le piège à vélo allez c'est
parti
fais-moi un bulle cet objet
voilà on est bien voilà du coup on a
foutu ça en plein milieu j'espère qu'il
y aura pas de vélo
je pense qu'on sort
ça y est
[Applaudissements]
pour que ce soit un truc bien
ok enfin après au moins une demi-heure
de galère là
-dedans
c'est super lourd au moins 30 kg
c'est de la faute
et si vous savez ce que c'est dites-le
nous on a une sorte d'aileron
ça va le faire couler la péniche
bon on va peser l'objet
113 donc 4 à 50 ça fait
on espère que vous avez apprécié cette
vidéo nous comme d'habitude on va
récupérer toute la Ferrari qu'on a
remonté aujourd'hui et j'ai revendu ses
inférieurs et voilà pas mal de
découvertes insolites aujourd'hui on n'a
pas eu d'énormes trouvailles on espère
que la semaine prochaine on aura un
petit peu plus de chance d'ici là
portez-vous bien